welcome to free
are you
lost
are you
scared
are you feeling all right
don't worry
i'll find you
i'm
[Music]
[Music]
this is the back rooms
that's all i have to say about that i've
talked a lot about the back rooms and i
think i've played at least one back
rooms game but it wasn't like i don't
want to say it was bad but i don't think
it was like very developed this one
looks a little more polished
so let's find out what's lurking in
the back rooms
first day of a new job
huge company
i don't even know what they do exactly
i was supposed to go to the archives to
sort out some documents
[Music]
i was supposed to go oh i didn't even re
i didn't even notice that it changed
lixie and read it for me
put this docs in cabinet liminal spaces
disappears abductions and glitches
la dag
okay i see
all right
wait
what does that say to get out of here
lost in
left
when
i i don't i can't read it
uh
what's that sound
what am i hearing
hearing something
ow
oh my god
what
what
[Music]
what
oh no
i guess i picked the wrong one
okay
i uh
uh oh
what okay i thought my neck was just
being broken in half okay well i'm in
the back rooms now okay so um given that
i've actually never read up anything on
the back rooms and i don't actually know
the reason of the back rooms i'm gonna
guess that there's probably a monster in
here that's gonna chase me and kill me
and eat my bones
thought i saw said monster that was
going to chase me and hate me i need my
bones
oh
um
is this like uh is this like a randomly
generated procedurally generated who's
he what's it
where the rooms constantly shift and
change all over the place or uh is it a
set map
i'm gonna get lost i'm gonna get so lost
i am so gonna get lost
which i think is the point that's the
point of the back rooms
is you get lost
okay
what happened
what happened
what do you mean are you quiet
why are you quiet
hello okay i see some writing over there
but why
that is
flowers
that's weird
help help i'm lost yeah me too pal
yeah me too
i hear something
oh
what
hello
oh
do i go down
hello
[Music]
oh i thought it was like one of those
things where you go you find the whole
then you go the next level down i didn't
think it was just going to be a you die
okay
fine i guess i have to
oh
what
what
is there a point to this
whoa
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
what where where what
i should run i'm gonna run now
why am i collecting pages
what does that sound how close are you
hello
your footsteps are real slumpy
hello what is that oh it's the goddamn
uh file go oh boy
how you doing chair what yeah [ __ ]
whoa hey ghosty goo what is this what am
i looking at why is there that shadow
there what is happening to any of this
what is going on
hi oh how do i get away from you um oh
oh
four four four four four there's numbers
there's numbers there's numbers why are
there numbers four four four on a drawer
i found four where's that chair i was
just here i saw it
what is over there something over there
what is going on here oh whoa
i think that's not right wait a minute
where's that dude what
i don't think this is supposed to happen
um
okay
well that ain't right
uh chair high chair
seven seven four four on a drawer seven
in heaven on a chair okay
i can do that
i can do that you
you
four seven was that
the
five five five four seven five
okay good
what
hello
what
exit
okay okay oh the code code code okay
there's one more thing it looked like a
desk
oh here
hey
nine uh four what does that say four
seven
five nine watch out for it
watch out for its butthole i think that
was all of them was that it
four seven five nine
is that it
i guess i just go back
oh god
oh
oh oh where are you
where are you
oh
oh oh oh
i don't see it
where are you at
oh god oh god i'm gonna get i'm gonna
get swamped ah there he is
there he is i think there was a long
hallway down this way i'm gonna get
swamped
oh god no okay here we go here we go yes
oh god that sounds close
what where's
where's what are you doing good thank
god oh hey
there he is what a big boy
yeah oh you gone
okay all right
yeah yeah yeah yeah here okay four seven
five nine okay uh the desk had a nine
five
seven
four nine five seven four was that it i
don't remember nine five seven four
oh i got it
oh
oh
oh i won okay
i thought there was going to be more to
it
ah
ah
okay all right
based on the creepypasta slash meme yeah
that that checks out if you like it or
not there's still a lot of a lot
of backrooms to explore
it's probably
randomly generated i bet it's like
something where things are mixed up all
the time i don't know where anything
else would be in there it seemed like
there was it was a box it seemed like it
was just a box but there probably were
some other places to like slip through
the walls that i didn't catch so if you
want to find those secrets link is in
the description this was not bad i liked
it i actually thought it was pretty good
moving on
welcome to dark dreams you ever had a
dream
or you didn't know where you were and
what you were doing and what what was
the thing that you were going to what
you were gonna do
and you were
trying to get the thing
and you didn't know how to do the what
you were gonna do this is that game
i think
are you sure all say progress will be
lost i didn't have any but it's ominous
this demo may contain texture glycerin
gameplay books and we work on fixing
these people with dark souls have
nothing but dark dreams
people with really dark souls do nothing
but dream
wise words i guess
oh i do oh
well radio
anyway
but anyway yeah that's on the back page
of uh qsc this month so
can i
fiddle with this
yeah i like this one better okay i'm
gonna use that one
um
find lantern
it i guess
uh take
light up oil lamp
ah amnesia style
is that on the radio or is that a real
big loud mouse
all right fine
am i dreaming
you
uh-huh
cool
oh
hi
what does that say
fallen pollen
allen
oh hi
oh
hi
are you whispering to me
are you trying to whisper sweet nothings
in my ear great appreciate it
ah
reed dear mrs johnson i have evaluated
your recent request for help regarding
your husband's mental state my
condolences go out to you and your
family however my hands are tied without
your husband's willingness to cooperate
and seek help there isn't anything i can
offer my
off-record advice to you is to get out
get out right now mrs johnson the
darkness won't stop get out
best of luck dr barron
um that's moderately concerning
but only moderate
i
okay
i
yes i yes
ah yes
yes
oh
okay
that's concerning
what's that all about
oh hi
hey what's up pal
how are you doing neighbor i'll just be
on my way
goodbye
um
okay
this room is not available in the demo
oh
hi
another friend um
yeah why not okay hey
that's a little bit of an extreme
reaction oh wait i was the monster i
jump scared you ah
return
okay
return what this does feel very
amnesia-like
and not just because of the lantern
although that does help
zoom
i love ce
sure
hi door is jammed someone's trying to
hold it shut
what we just won't do
that just won't do we won't just do any
nothing about that hello
it's a cop
this is our new house do you come to
visit us
sure
oh and axe
can i use that that'd be helpful a spine
maybe i could get one and i'd be brave
enough there must be something here
that can help me with it that is
apparently not
this axe right here
oh
there's something ticking behind this
bookshelf what
is there
oh
wait
ah
oh i like that oh my god i don't like
that hey
oh
i'm sorry
what
oh oh
oh
ah
thanks that's it you're gonna end it
there
nothing happened but nothing happened
i can break this i can break you
i can break you
and i'm stuck
i consider this me breaking this lexian
hit it with it
so not bad very short not substantial uh
it looked good and it had a good feel to
it there just wasn't a lot there and i
wasn't even really much of a demo to get
an idea of what the story was going to
be really really short but interesting
you know i'd be interested in playing a
further game of that definitely but for
now i have to
move on
[Music]
this is the red hood
i don't know if it's related in any way
to red riding hood but it is red hood
oh
run never stop choose the right way to
avoid a strange serial killer from the
forest if you die you will start the
game from the beginning ps good luck you
need it oh good whoa so we're not gonna
have a relaxing time this is all stress
all the time
good
run and never stop does that mean i
should not look behind me
oh oh i you now oh oh oh
oh well what's the worst that could
happen
i'm
i'm dead okay i get it okay okay all
right don't stop the redness is chasing
you okay
i gotta get it i gotta get this basket
to grandma
oh but i gotta choose a right past is
there gonna be like a clue there's glowy
to the right is that saying i need to go
right oh
not now not now
okay that thing uh that red mist is uh
quick
okay all right um uh oh uh die that way
die this way both ways or die
uh
okay
i'm taking in as much environment as i
can my eyes have never been more open
which way die that way die this way i
stick to the right
oh oh
ow ow ow your hood ow your hood isn't
red which makes me assume i'm red riding
hood oh god
okay so
i don't know if there was a clue or if
that was random chance but there must
have been a clue because if it's just
random chance then i'm never gonna make
it out of here
maybe the light maybe the light i did go
right the light was right
so i don't see anything else besides
these big like lamppost things but there
was a glowing right on the right unless
it's not randomly generated and it's all
the same
which it could be
could be
let's only try left
next time
sure is misty around here
left
oh god
okay so far so good so far so good
um left left maybe it's the number of
land posts on each side that's a right
lamppost
okay
uh oh no oh three
three
kill me okay middle middle was good
we like the middle what does that mean
what is that about what's this left
right i went right i said left no not
that way
okay it's fine it's fine it's fine okay
that was good that was good oh god why
this yes yes
you're never gonna get me
i'm too quick
oh no no no oh yes yes
yes
i i i will never remember the ways that
i've gone i do not remember and i will
never remember
i don't remember and i can't remember
i'm going the right way apparently
i don't know how
oh god
no
oh
it's fi i'm doing it
guys i'm doing it
uh
nope nope not that way not that way not
that way
not that yes
i'm never ever ever going to remember
that how would i
ever remember that i can kind of get a
little extra speed going the strapy but
if you
if you walk into the mist and it's misty
then
it kind of i can't move after that so
i'm kind of locked in oh god what was
even the first way i think it was right
i think right
yeah right
not it probably doesn't matter oh god it
is awfully foggy on some of these paths
that are correct
not that way and it was not that way
yeah and now i'm officially lost i have
no idea which way i'm going
i have no idea
i have no idea
i have no idea
i don't know
that looks bad that looks bad that looks
bad it's okay that's the fake out one
okay so from here i believe i went
to the
right
i don't remember i don't remember i
don't remember i don't remember i don't
remember i remembered apparently i
remembered i remembered i remembered
and then which way did i go and die i
think i went left and died so i need to
go right and not die
this looks like
okay and this is right and don't die
okay it's excessive man okay one more
time into the breach i got this i got
this hey everybody shut up i got it
fake out fog
i believe it's left
oh god
oh come on that's oh it was right oh man
it's yeah that was so far down
oh man i'm never gonna make it i'm never
ever gonna make it i'm never ever she's
never gonna make it
the next one is a right this is fake out
fog
okay fake out fog that's good then go
right
it's a right
i'm 100 sure it's a right you go right
yes yes good
and then is is this word starts going
left two lefts
is this the two lefts
two left one left
two lefts
yes
oh i don't remember i don't remember
anything
and then i need to go right left
no
no not left right
need to go right
need to go right it looks bad but it's
right oh what they're both
they're both wrong
oh it must be because i'm not i don't
know
oh
so no matter what you do you die that's
the moral of the story not bad i like
the idea of like a fast-paced game i
played one of them like that it was a
little like more subdued than this this
one did kind of have the stress to it i
mean it's not a lot of like game going
on this is like guessing paths um but
there is something very fascinating
about running it's why endless runners
are so
so fascinating so you could make like i
believe you could make a good horror
running game but it would have to have
some more components to it but this was
still very good for a demo great loved
it good
moving on
warning this game contains potentially
disturbing subject matters and
tryptophobia-inducing imagery great
i love tryptophobia we all know this
welcome to how fish is made
i'm a little confused as to what's
happening here uh sure
ow
oh it's me hi
hello where are we
what is uh
is this the fish factory
i assume we'd see how fish are made
unless we're gonna see the miracle of
life
oh
hello you just dropped
tell me are you going up or down well i
just came from the up to the down which
i'm assuming is this
you'll have to make up your mind by the
end
even the oiliest of us have to
so don't flatter yourself with your
choice
where am i going don't worry about that
so which is it up or down
um
all right i'll go i'll go down
up down up down up down up down dog i'm
going down uh we're all going down
someday
are you sure
well not anymore
better be sure
wow
what do you mean
what do you mean
what do you mean what do you mean also
where are we and how are we surviving
out of water and will this cup need to
be
by the way the machine can't talk to you
so you shouldn't talk to it
okay thank you
is this going to cut me to ribbons
all right i seem to be fine is anyone
else getting heavy cry of fear vibes
which is a game that i have not played
in ages
hi
this is really comfortable to flop on
all right
how are you doing
hey what's up
a pop-up
you look like a smart guy you also know
the ways one way and that way is up and
ain't no two ways about it
i've always known it was up i never
asked i never changed never lied
let me hear you sing it i'd like to hear
it where are you going where you going
well you're a little too enthusiastic
about up uh and i'm one to stick to my
guns my gut told me down
so down i go where's it say come again
not so floppy anymore down
wonder what will happen to you will it
hurt will it stop oh well
okay
oh
all right hey what are you
oh it's like soda thing
ah what fortune that we should meet do
not be foiled by that one he is lost
like so many are
we can only
poetry them i see you are in awe of my
throne of inspiration
they clung to me suddenly one day much
like all my ideas do complete and undone
undeniable
undentable complete and undentable
no no take it in as much as you like it
is a confirmation of my most oily brain
do tell what blind groping has brought
you to your choice
before warned i did a lot of thinking to
know which end is indeed the correct way
all answers come to me very quickly
such is my burden
would you like to know it might change
your entire worldview
it is down yes this i know for sure but
how i hear you ask let me explain no
this is simply too complex for you to
phantom
my methods are beyond simple minds
i have never ever thought of a single
reason to question myself can you
believe it
no you cannot
i am elated to have saved you from
making a father embarrassment of
yourself
just think of me as your guide mentor
and sage
you're welcome
i'm really questioning my gut feeling to
go down
my throne no no no it's not
uncomfortable at all
can i join you in said throne is there
room for two all right goodbye well this
is not very reassuring as to what i'm
supposed to do also i have no idea why
i'm here but such question seems to be
beyond me at the moment
is that a butthole great
oh hi hello how are you
oh hello um the way he's over there
yeah uh-huh
i don't know what to do my family went
up but my best bud said the down is the
correct choice
the family is big but distant in their
togetherness but the big group together
is safest it's a toughest is truth why
would he do this to me down is wrong i
could feel it between my shiniest flakes
we've swam together since both of us
were less crampy things but
how can i know if you'll agree to always
be my friend no one cares about how i
feel not even him but i want to choose
if i can't know exactly how it'll turn
out
you you which way should i go up with
the family or down with my buddy you
know the saying blood is thicker than
water but that's just a fragment of the
saying the the true saying is like the
blood of the covenant is thicker than
the water of the womb which means the
blood of the people that you choose to
be with
is uh
thicker than familial traits somehow
that phrase got turned upside down go
down upside down go down
really
i've i've been so stupid i can't make
decisions for myself my buddy always
sold me as much he'll be angry when i
join him but he always tells me how to
earn his forgiveness
i won't make this mistake again oh how
wonderful oh good there's freedom of
certainty maybe i've made the right
choice oh by the way you're going the
same way right
actually yes
oh
god good
not that it mattered anymore
i'll be seeing you
what
well i mean i am going down but uh
i guess you really went through with it
uh should i have talked to the other
ones more ah some nice
what i'm hoping is water well that was
refreshing that's all i need down into
the butthole i go
you know i said butthole is a joke but
i'm thinking this
actually i think it might actually be a
butthole or a sphincter of some kind
hallelu
is this how fish is made
up yeah oh yes
that's a butthole
is that a condom
is that a condom
hi
behold what did we do to deserve bearing
witness to such glory
it must mean something
but what what is it trying to say
i've groped through my noggin
i've eyed every detail i don't
understand the message
there must be a way out of this
creature's stomach the answer is here it
looks down upon us
what is it revealing
well you know i'm kind of locked into
this whole down thing
yes yes i can see it but can you it has
to be
behold
it swallowed us down so we must keep
going down
first i must get inside i must be
cleansed by this untainted substance
join me wash with me in his purity
i are you talking about the condom
are you talking about the
white substance in the condom oh to be
chosen for sublime anointment
i truly envy him i must become worthy
yeah okay
um
uh okay so all this analogy about going
down have we been eating is this all in
analyst what is that
is this all an analogy for being eaten
because i'm beginning to think that it's
something like that but i don't know why
someone would swallow a
a used condom hi you okay you talkable i
don't want to touch it
a little i'm
how about no you know what actually
i'm gonna go with no
all of this i'm just gonna say no and
i'm gonna leave i ain't coming back
hey i'm going down
no matter what
is that a squish-o-matic uh sure looks
like a squish-o-matic um hey
um
oh boy a big red button a smashy doo and
a what looks like a fish stuck in the
gears hey what's up
oh oh
please tell me
it's embarrassing but i thought i had
found the gills of this creature that
swallowed us
so i figured i'd wriggle my way out
through them
but who would have thought they were not
gills if it's not too much of a bother
could you unstuck me
thank you ever so much for your kindness
oh wait hold on
this is important
whatever you do just make sure not to
touch that round red glowing thing over
there okay
thanks
what a relief i thought i might be stuck
in here forever
uh but
i don't really see another way to get
you unstuck
i can barely feel my fins are they still
there
uh yeah
um is there like something i could get
to jam in the machine
i got a bad feeling about this one i
think i'm gonna have to push for a
bigger red button
hey can you help out with this uh
button situation fish down if you know
what i mean
okay all right um
oh no
well you're dead clearly oh no
okay this is what i'm thinking and
follow my logic here
so this is a condom right that's
straight up right okay
the weird white substance what if it's
not
semen what if it's lube
what if it's not what i think it is and
what if it's lube and that could help
get that fish out of the gears you said
something about anointing ourself in the
thing so i'm just gonna belly flop right
in
i was wrong
i was wrong i don't feel any different
i feel slightly dirtier one more try
yep all right you know i thought
i really thought i thought i was on to
something turns out it was the worst
option turns out i dove head first into
a used condom
sometimes life throws you curveballs now
you don't know how to recover you just
have to live with the knowledge that you
did that in front of
all of you and i will never be let
forgotten
okay well either i chuck myself in there
which uh what are you what are you doing
i warned you did i touch it
somebody help me i didn't touch it did i
touch it oh i got close to it he was
scared
don't worry i ain't gonna touch it
i'm gonna touch it
i pressed it oh no
oh
my god
hi hey
how you doing look oh god
it could have been worse it could have
ended up in a used condom uh
wow well this looks
oddly appetizing okay goodbye
[Music]
all right let's uh let's just pretend
that uh there was no way around that and
there was nothing i could do because
down is the way that i need to go and
anything that gets in the way of me and
down is
oh it's bad oh yes bye
we go what am i looking at what cheese
oh i hope cheese it's not cheese
i don't know what that is but it's not
cheese i don't know i don't want to
ponder it i don't want to ponder it
i don't want to ponder it
oh
[Applause]
good
oh good this is good
we
what a fun time hey i don't think this
is water
i don't think it's water what's under
there oh
secret secrets
can't be kept from me
oh god no
oh shield your eyes oh my god what is
that oh my god
oh it should have been kept a secret
secret it should have been kept a secret
secret it should have been kept a sacred
secret
what
well this has been a delightful
adventure i am horrified it's just a
different type of
scary
more of a repulsion than scare
although i am perturbed and unsettled
hello
hello
i don't want it i didn't do it
okay everything's fine totally fine i
shouldn't go back i'm curious though but
i won't go back high
[Music]
what's up with you i gotta go back and
see what that noise is it might have
been nothing but i can't alright choice
has been made i can't go back hi
oh god
oh my god
aha
well fortunately you dropped into this
most productive places
him
by me and my friend oh here go way back
i ate his tongue and we've been
co-workers ever since
i'll bet you we have a lot of learnings
we can share
i always say you have to get passionate
about something me
i'm passionate about friendship i want
to be there for people as much as
possible
it's like my buddy here always says
teamwork is the soul of success
i think that's beautiful
now well by golly i've been struck by
the most brilliant of ideas
would you mind if i incentivize you with
a little musical stylings of my own
grace
my friendo does so enjoy a little show
tune here and there
all right then hold onto gills
what
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
oh
um
well hopefully lixian uh spared you from
the worst of that i have a bad feeling
if i press this again it's just gonna
play this whole song again
well buddy how are we feeling synced
with success aligned with ambition oh
you know it baby
no doubt about my buddy my pal i dare
say i snuck a little bit of my
core competence in yeah you'll feel it
real soon uh oh
what did you sneak in me okay keep it
moving bal
uh what do you mean core competent what
did you sneak in me
[Music]
oh no
oh where's my tongue still there okay
all right cool bye
[Music]
goodbye now
goodbye
oh what did i get myself into i'm going
up not down i want to go down what is
this
okay
everybody having a good time
what is this
what is this
what is
okay i see something dripping oh yeah i
see a lot of dripping
oh wow
good
hello
i can't even go oh no
oh no come on oh no
oh
no
if i just squint my ass i can't see him
i'll just keep my head real squinty i
can't see him
i can't see him
i can't see him
i can't see him i can barely see
anything i see nothing
i see nothing
oh my god why oh no
why do you deserve it what will you be
able to live with it
try and try and try and try and try
again
ah those double action hinges have
always been there just for you right
you'll come back everyone does
weak or you go looking
one way or another right
weak
okay anyway goodbye
i guess they're not that bad as long as
i don't let them be that bad
okay goodbye i don't care how weak i am
i'm getting out of here
i'm going down
[Music]
maybe i should have gone up maybe up
would have been better
oh it's okay i was about to say oh it's
almost beautiful
hi
[Music]
this looks so special
[Music]
can't wait to see where this is going
oh hi
what is that
behind you
i cry
it is time
well you know i've come this far up
sticking to my guns on this one
i see
do you understand yet
well kind of
not i'm gonna say no actually
this privilege of choice that has been
given to a worthless critter like you
that is the gift
not the outcome
did the uncertainty scare you or does it
scare you more to know there is no
choice for you at all
then all of this would have been for
nothing
but wouldn't you feel better
don't flatter yourself
i'll tell you a secret
you've already made your choice
this is not about making a decision
this is a test of conviction
have you strayed from your path not
really i guess have you been honest and
true to your truth even to others
uh ye technically yeah
did you believe me just now
i'm just a fish in an imposing room
good enough right
i suppose i wouldn't eat any of those
they taste awful
okay well anyway i stuck to my guns i
don't know about you pal
i stayed true through and through what
am i looking at now you know what the
longer i ponder it the more i'll dive
into insanity so i shan't ponder
where do i go down on this sucker
where's this bad boy go down point me to
the down
escalator what is this um
fishtail this is the line for the down
hello
hi how you doing you're a big fish ain't
you
[Music]
this is really it huh
i'll level with you ain't real sure i
can do this
did you run into that smart talking
fella earlier they sure didn't seem to
know what he was talking about
here i've been always thinking i'm the
biggest thing in the water
look at me now a big old boy shivering
like a scrap out in the blue
anyway i thought keeping track of how
many fish went in either direction could
help
and i'm sure it did it all let me tell
you
reckon you want to hear how many have
gone each way not really
ride on partners swim your own way
all right youtube pal i'm headed down
[Music]
see you around fella
i'm guessing blue means down because
here i go i am always certain
i am through and true and through to
true to you
downey rooney
clearly the right option clearly
clearly down we go can you imagine ever
anyone being on up team
you imagine it
you know i always hated hearing
don't worry
a lot of people are going through the
same thing
you're not alone
there's this selfish barbed wire inside
my chest that coils up at that
no
my pain is more tragic grander deeper
if only you knew
that's not true of course
i hate talking about it
because i hate people who talk about it
and that's not very nice
that's not okay that's not how you can
be about all this
it's not romantic
but at least it's true
don't worry
a lot of people are going through the
same thing
and that's what makes it the best usp
yet
thanks for playing what's the usp
can anything beat home cooking straight
off the conveyor belt
these fish are so fresh they might just
give you a little wink and jump right
off the plate into your mouth
a no meal that can't be kicked into high
gear with the addition of nature's own
flavor torpedoes so indulging the
oiliest saltiest sardines served every
day by our ingeniously creative kitchen
artists take pride in knowing you helped
bring these little troopers to our
plates friends that's not flattery
that's a fact
cool
all right anyway i loved it i hated it
but also i kind of loved it i'm a sucker
for a musical anyway
great good stuff play it for yourself
what direction will you choose
link in description
[Music]
did you enjoy it
did you
find your way back
i know you did
but don't worry
i found you
[Music]